all right guys so lovely to meet you I
love that I love the fits you guys look
really really good how do you you got
Sparkles um
but you guys sort of I guess in a sense
are also matching because you feel the
sort of standing Warrior rolls for this
for this series and you kind of do a
little bit more of the heavy lifting
than sort of the rest of the party can
you talk me through a little bit of the
what the training process was like you
know how do you learn to fight with a
sword or you know do all the other sort
of Fantastical things that you do for
this show yeah well we did a 30-day long
boot camp
where we before we even started on
camera we we learned to sword fight and
uh horse ride and we did a little
rehearsal and character building time
and then
um we did around two hours of personal
training a day
um so we all got quite strong and quite
fit which gave us the stamina and the
sword fighting was was intense but
incredible but that that period of time
gave us the opportunity to
develop a fighting style that was our
own
um and unique to the characters and so
it became organic and it was yeah really
great Omar you all also are in The Wheel
of Time which is a sort of separate High
fantasy series is there any sort of are
there similarities between working on
that and working on this or is sort of
you know Disney and then that sort of
two separate Realms entirely yeah I
think the the scale of that show is is
so tremendous and the story is so rich
and and It prepares you for this world
that you have to step onto and not be
too blindsided by the fact that you're
in a ginormous Castle
um in films there um so it was you know
it's helpful to have been there and meet
those incredible actors and work on it
but um
but Willow although it has a similar
sense of scale it was a much smaller
concept really it was like let's take
this Motley Crew and push them through
to their limits and see how they develop
and that was a really lovely thing to do
yeah and so uh Aaron you play into the
sort of night and and Princess sort of
romance Trope quite a bit in this show
and it's very much the emotional core of
the series so what was that like sort of
I guess being the emotional core of the
show
uh I I think it's quite ironic because I
think when you first meet Jade she um
has a really tight hard time expressing
her emotions I think she pushes a lot of
stuff down I just think
there's a lot of things from her her
past and how she feels and her yeah I
think she finds it quite hard to express
herself
um and it's quite nice you see her go on
this journey and and ease up a little
bit and she realizes she doesn't have to
quite keep everything in and sort of
similarly to that that the original film
is very much the story of Hope and
perseverance and sort of togetherness
and obviously the show the show you know
exudes that quite a bit what do you guys
hope people take from this series that's
maybe a little bit different from the
film
I think it's just it's just modernized
in the sour word yeah modernized in the
uh issues that are addressed I think
um the things that the characters go
through have just become more modern as
the world has changed
um
and I think the things that are kind of
in this
magical world or just metaphors for for
more real life things that people are
going through yeah and I don't think
it's overtly political or anything like
that it's it's just a diverse group of
personalities more than anything all
learning that they're going through
something together and trying to figure
out who they are and what you know what
their purpose is and that's reflective
of the real world and that's the nicest
thing about it is it does that with
humor and magic and in beautiful forests
it does and it's it's absolutely
wonderful but thank you guys so much for
talking to me today I had a wonderful
time take care